hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd and
big fan of sunscreen
today i'm going to be talking about the
do's and don'ts of sunscreens what
should you
and shouldn't you do this video is
sponsored by adore beauty australia's
biggest online only beauty retailer they
sell lots of face sunscreens including
some of my personal favorites
stick around because i'm going to be
going through some of those at the end
i've also got adore beauty's joe fleming
to talk about some of her favorites too
you might know her from the beauty iq
uncensored podcast
i have oily skin and jo has drier skin
so between us we've probably got you
covered for a good sunscreen
recommendation
we also did a sunscreen q a that's
posted on the adore beauty channel so
check that out too
if you like finding out more about the
science behind beauty products click the
like
the subscribe and click the notification
bell so you don't miss any videos
alright let's get into it
firstly do wear sunscreen daily
sunscreen isn't just for the beach
if you're serious about skin care you
should be wearing sunscreen every day
there is a bit of wiggle room here if
the uv index is below 3
then according to australian medical
authorities you don't have to wear
sunscreen
but since you're here watching a
skincare video you probably care about
sun damage
and you're probably using some
anti-aging ingredients in your skin care
so unless you want to be wasting all of
that hard work and money
then you should be probably wearing
sunscreen every day some anti-aging
ingredients like alpha hydroxy acids
also make your skin more sensitive to
the sun and so that makes wearing daily
sunscreen more of a priority
daily sunscreen might even be important
if you work indoors near a window
there are longer uv rays called uva rays
and these still penetrate through
glass and even though they don't cause
burning they do cause premature aging
i have another video about how to work
out if you need sunscreen indoors and
i'll link that in the description
do wear enough sunscreen the first rule
of sunscreen club
is use enough sunscreen a little goes a
long way is a lie when it comes to
sunscreen
the less sunscreen you have on your skin
the less protection you get
you can think of sunscreen like paint if
you don't have enough on you're not
hiding your skin well enough
from the sun the standard recommendation
for face sunscreen is a quarter teaspoon
or two finger lengths and that's like
two generous ish finger lengths
when in doubt apply more you're going to
need more than a thin
layer to get enough sun protection do
wear sunscreen under makeup
all sunscreens chemical physical or even
combo go
on your skin at the end of your skincare
routine
so this means it goes over any serums or
creams you're using
and under your makeup so that includes
primer foundation concealer blush
it's a myth that you need to apply
chemical and physical sunscreens
differently
chemical sunscreens don't need to react
with your skin to activate or anything
but both types of sunscreens need some
time to
form an even layer on your skin getting
this nice even smooth layer
is how you get even sun protection it's
a bit like how you need to wait a little
bit for wall paint to flatten out and
for the brush strokes to
disappear after you've applied your
sunscreen wait five to ten minutes for
your sunscreen to settle down and form
this even layer
before you start putting on your makeup
and that little wait time means that
your sunscreen is less likely to get
removed when you start putting on your
makeup
do reapply sunscreen sunscreen gets less
effective over time
it's just like foundation when it's on
your skin it starts clumping up as
time goes on and so you don't end up
with that even layer that you need
anymore
these gaps in your sunscreen layer means
that the sun can get through and reach
your skin
sunscreen can also get wiped off onto
anything that it brushes against so your
hair
your hands your clothes so if you put on
sunscreen in the morning and then you
plan to go to the beach in the afternoon
you need to reapply your sunscreen
before you go to the beach
if you're out in the sun for an extended
period of time you should be reapplying
your sunscreen about every two hours
and you should be reapplying after you
get wet so for example if you're
sweating a lot
or if you go swimming i have another
video that goes into detail about
different ways of reapplying sunscreen
especially over makeup
my favorite way is to use a puff
applicator and pattern on very gently
over my makeup
and i found that this if i use the right
sunscreen and if i'm really gentle
it mostly doesn't mess up my makeup now
for a don't
don't rely on the sunscreen in your
makeup so remember how you need enough
sunscreen for it to be effective
and remember how that means you need a
quarter teaspoon or two finger lengths
well you're not going to put on that
much makeup so a foundation with spf in
it isn't enough
and a powder with spf in it definitely
isn't enough
you're going to need a proper sunscreen
don't
mix makeup into your sunscreen it's
really tempting to mix sunscreen and
foundation in your hand to make like a
diy tinted sunscreen
and so that way you only have to put on
one layer but this is not
a good idea for a sunscreen to work well
it has to form an even continuous layer
on your skin
you aren't going to be able to mix these
products as evenly as a machine
and so you won't get even coverage
you'll also change how the sunscreen
applies and dries on your skin and so
you'll end up with a layer that won't
dry the way that the manufacturers
intended it to dry
and you'll end up with uneven coverage
and spots where you don't have enough
protection
if you do want to just apply everything
in one step then look for a proper
tinted sunscreen
but remember that you still need to
apply enough of it for it to be
effective
so look for one that isn't super
pigmented don't
use expired sunscreen sunscreen is one
of the few skincare products where you
can have really bad consequences
if it isn't working properly anymore
which is what happens when it expires
it's best to play it safe and buy a new
sunscreen if your old sunscreen is past
the expiry date
also don't store your sunscreen in the
heat
sunscreens will break down and separate
if it's exposed to too much heat
that means it won't spread right on your
skin and so it won't give you that even
protection that you need and you'll get
gaps in your coverage
places like your car glove box are not a
good place to keep your sunscreen if you
do want to have a sunscreen with you
keep it in your handbag
when you're at the beach as well make
sure you don't just leave the sunscreen
bottle lying in the sun cover it up and
leave it in the shade
do make sure you pick a sunscreen that
you enjoy
when you choose a sunscreen the most
important thing is to choose a sunscreen
that you'll actually use
if it just lies around sitting on the
shelf after you've used it once and you
hate it
then there's no point because everyone's
so much more knowledgeable about sun
protection these days
there's been a lot of really nicely
textured sunscreens that have been
launched onto the market
and so don't think that all sunscreens
are like heavy greasy body sunscreens
there are lots of sunscreens that go on
like primer or moisturizer
in terms of chemical versus physical
sunscreens i've done another video on
the differences between them and the
pros and cons of each one
but in short there are great sunscreens
in both categories
the best sunscreen for you is going to
depend on what you want in a sunscreen
and what your skin is like as a very
general rule of thumb
if your biggest problem with sunscreen
so far is texture
i recommend trying out a chemical
sunscreen first
and if your biggest problem is
irritation i'd recommend trying out a
physical sunscreen first
now on to some sunscreen recommendations
like i said earlier i have oily skin and
so when i'm looking for a sunscreen i
tend to go for really light textures
i'm also really prone to
hyperpigmentation from sun damage on my
dad's side we have lots and lots of
sunspots and so
i look for really high uva protection so
most of my favorites
are chemical sunscreens adult beauty
stock a lot of sunscreens and that
includes one of my favorite sunscreen
brands
ultraviolet ultraviolet are an
australian brand and they focus on
making sunscreens with really nice
textures
they work well under makeup and they
still give that high protection that
we're all looking for in australia
my favorite of their sunscreens is the
supreme screen so this is the one with
the yellow cap
it comes in a nice pump i really like
pumps because they're so
convenient to use it's very lightweight
and it feels like it sinks in very
quickly it leaves a silky texture on
your skin
it makes a really good makeup base it
has a primer-like finish
and when you put makeup on top it
doesn't ball up which is sometimes quite
hard to find
this has some of the newer generation
organic filters like tinosorb air
centenosome m
and these give really good protection in
that uva range that i care about with my
sunspots
if you like mineral sunscreens their
lean screen is one of the least
white casty sunscreens i've ever tried
and some darker skin people have tried
it too
and it has a pretty good texture for a
mineral sunscreen so it's not super
super heavy
so one of my faves which i think you
might have just spoken about michelle is
the
ultraviolet lean screen which is a
mineral sunscreen i've got dry to normal
skin
and i was expecting this to be a lot
thicker than it
actually is i actually found it really
pleasant to use
and to be honest the fragrance free part
is probably the best part because i
think a lot of people find that
um quite frustrating when looking for a
sunscreen because that smell kind of
hangs around on your skin all day
but this one just blends into the skin
beautifully and on dry
skin totally fine i haven't had an issue
with it
um in terms of killing i know that um
that has come up with a few people
um when i've been talking about it and i
actually had an experience with peeling
with this product but
i realized that it was actually the
serum that i was using
underneath it that was the problem and
once i eliminated that serum
we were like good to go if you are a lot
drier and you're finding that when
you're up when you are blending it out
with your fingers
that you're getting that killing try
using a moisturizer underneath because
that worked for me as well
using something a bit more hydrating
underneath and then popping this over
the top
and helped with the peeling for me so
that's my tips when it comes to
lean screen another sunscreen i really
love from adore beauty is the aspect sun
and virustat face spf 50. this is a
chemical sunscreen and unusually for a
face sunscreen
it has four hours water resistance it's
a bit thicker than the sunscreens i
usually use but it's not super thick
it's not greasy
and so it is the most comfortable water
resistant sunscreen i've ever used
one issue i tend to have with sunscreens
especially with water resistant
sunscreens is that because they're
trying to form that waterproof film
they tend to break up when you put on
makeup so sometimes they ball up a bit
more
than non-waterproof ones this does peel
a little bit when i put on makeup
but again it's the least pilly of the
water resistant sunscreens i've used
and so this is my new go-to when i know
i'm going to sweat or if i know i'm
going to get water exposure like if i'm
going kayaking or swimming
the one drawback of this is that it
doesn't have those newer uva filters
ideally i'd also want to have the newer
sunscreen filters in this for better uva
protection
but it is broad spectrum according to
australian regulations and so that means
that the uva projection is already
pretty decently
high so my next one is going to be alpha
h's protection plus spf 50.
this is a chemical sunscreen broad
spectrum protection spf 50.
i have used this sunscreen for probably
about three years
and i still consistently go back to it
there's something about it it goes on
like it's tinted but then it's not
tinted but it makes your skin just look
a little bit more airbrushed i don't
think that's the right word but it just
makes your skin look more even
so when you're not wearing makeup you're
going to the beach or just on a daily
basis and you like to wear makeup this
is a
great product i really like it it is
probably
a little bit um mattifying for a very
dry skin type
but for anyone else i would say this is
perfect it's a bit of an all-rounder
beautiful texture i might actually show
you so you can see it kind of comes out
tinted like that
but then as you rub it in it just kind
of goes
translucent so it doesn't leave i've got
quite fair skin
and it doesn't leave a tint for me so i
really love that one it does kind of
smell like hay though
like you've been out feeding horses or
something so i don't know
what i think it's meant to be fragrance
free but it kind of has a smell of hay
just
fyi i also really like the skinceuticals
ultra facial defense spf 50 plus
this sunscreen uses a lot of those
filters that tend to give higher
protection so it has tunosub s maxor sx
and xl
and your vinyl a plus this sunscreen is
a combo sunscreen so it also has
titanium dioxide titanium dioxide tends
to give
a white cast on my skin so this one
going on has that white cast
but it actually fades away pretty
quickly after the layer settles down
it is a little bit dewy and sticky on my
skin especially because we're going into
summer and it's getting quite humid
but it's very moisturizing and it's not
super greasy
my next one is probably my all-time
favorite the most
expensive which is a shame because it's
a really beautiful sunscreen especially
for drier skin types um
i wouldn't suggest this one for oilier
skins because i think it'll probably
cause a bit too much
dewyness um on the skin but it's the
mesoaesthetic light water anti-aging
veil
they've got quite a few different
sunscreens in their range
but oh my god the texture of this is
just
stunning for a drier skin it just gives
you
like the most beautiful glow
blends into the skin beautifully you
know how you've got to use quite a lot
of sunscreen to actually get the full
protection this just glides on like even
if you're using a lot of it
feels amazing on the skin has a
beautiful fragrance as well
and it is great for more mature skin
types as well so i really really love
this one they've also got a matte
version too
and they've got a little stick version
as well which you can use for eyes and
lips so
i absolutely love that one as well and
these three will probably just be
in my collection for the rest of my life
have you tried any of these sunscreens
before or do you have a really good
sunscreen recommendation especially a
water resistant one because i'm always
looking for
better water resistant sunscreens let me
know in the comments
i hope you liked this video if you did
give it a thumbs up and subscribe
you can also follow me on instagram and
check out my blog for more beauty
science
you can also follow adore beauty for
more on all things beauty
see you next time to nerd out more